مرحبًا بكم في البرنامج ، الجميع أنا
كريستيان أمانبور في لندن ،
جو بايدن يقترب يومًا ما من
تولي زمام القيادة في البيت الأبيض اليوم ،
أعلن الرئيس المنتخب رسميًا عن
مستشاريه الاقتصاديين الكبار ،
وهذا يتبع تسمية فرق
الاتصالات والسياسة الخارجية
قادة العالم  يستعدون
للانخراط مع نوع جديد تمامًا من
القيادة الأمريكية التي ستتبع بلا شك نهجًا أكثر صرامة
تجاه الرجال الأقوياء في الخارج
مثل الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح
دونالد ترامب ذات مرة أطلق عليه ذات مرة ديكتاتوري المفضل
بينما تعهد بايدن هذا الصيف
بأنه سيحصل على  لا مزيد من الشيكات الفارغة من
أمريكا
تولى السيسي السلطة في أعقاب انقلاب عام 2013
الذي أطاح بأول
رئيس منتخب ديمقراطياً في مصر
بعد الربيع العربي ، ومنذ ذلك الحين
قام
بقمع المجتمع المدني والمعارضة
والمدافعين عن حقوق الإنسان
ثلاثة أعضاء بارزين في واحد من
أكثر البلاد احتراماً.
تم القبض على مجموعات حقوق الإنسان
وسجنها بتهم تتعلق بالإرهاب  بعد لقائهما
بعشرات الدبلوماسيين الغربيين ، كان
كريم إنارة
أحدهم مخرجًا للمبادرة المصرية
للحقوق
الشخصية ، زوجة إنارة ، المخرجة البريطانية ، جيس
كيلي ، تقول إن
الأسوأ قد حدث ، كنا نخشى دائمًا أن
يكون حسام بهجت
هو مؤسس المنظمة.
وقد تم احتجازه أيضًا
لعدة أيام في عام 2015
، وكلاهما ينضم إلي الآن ، جيس
كيلي ،
مرحبًا بك في البرنامج ، واسمحوا لي
فقط أن أسألك في ملاحظة شخصية
كيف حالك ، وهل كنت
قادرًا على ذلك
في أي وقت  بأي طريقة للتواصل مع
زوجك المسجون ،
شكرًا لاستضافتي ، لقد كان الأمر
صعبًا حقًا
كل يوم هو تحد جديد
بعض الأيام أفضل من غيرها
لم أر
أو أسمع من كريم منذ
اعتقاله أه
قبل أسبوعين هل لديك أي شيء  فكرة
عن الظروف
التي يحتجز فيها ، أعني أننا نعلم
على الأقل أننا تحدثنا في
الصحافة أنه
في سجن طرة نعلم أنه
مكان سيء السمعة.
لقد أطلق عليه آل إنك
تعرف مكانًا
به ظروف غير إنسانية وقاسية ،
هل تعرف أي شيء
عن الظروف التي يعيش فيها ، هل
لديه محام على سبيل المثال ،
حسنًا اليوم تم التأكيد على أن
كريم محتجز في الحبس الانفرادي
وهو أمر مخيف ومروع للغاية
الوحي بالنسبة لي ،
كريم هو شخص اجتماعي بشكل لا يصدق ،
كان يوم أمس عيد ميلاده
، وفكرة أنه لم يتم التحدث
إلى شخص واحد لمدة أسبوعين
هي أمر مرعب بالنسبة لنا جميعًا ،
فأنت تعرف وظيفته كمدير
للعدالة الجنائية  الوحدة ،
إنه الشخص الذي يزور عادة
الأشخاص في السجن
أم أنه يعرف كل شيء عن الظروف
داخل السجون
أم أنه من دواعي سروري الوحيد هو
أنك تعرف على الأقل أن لديه بعض
الخبرة عما يمر
به ولديه محامون لديه
محامو أم إبر
ولكن نظام العدالة في مصر لدرجة
أنك تعلم أنهم ليسوا
قادرين على تمثيله في الواقع اليوم ، كانت هناك
جلسة استماع
وتمكنوا من الحضور ولكن
لم يكن هناك
أه تعلم أنه لم يكن هناك دفاع
عن كريم ولم يكونوا قادرين على التحدث
إليه
باستثناء كلمتين.